we welcome you to cbs mornings we're
going to begin with this there may be
some movement today on the availability
of coveted booster shots for americans
an fda advisory committee plans to vote
today on whether pfizer's booster shot
is safe and whether it's effective now
most experts believe the new doses are
in fact safe but there is some
disagreement over whether they're
necessary for all americans as ed
o'keefe reports the white house wants to
start the booster shot rollout as soon
as next week
we can take care of america and help the
world at the same time in august
president biden announced his plans to
get booster shots into arms as early as
september 20th to fight the coronavirus
will make you safer
and for longer
and will help us end the pandemic faster
but getting the fda to approve a third
shot of the pfizer vaccine before that
date will be an uphill battle pfizer
says people who received a booster shot
six to eight months after their second
dose of the vaccine tripled their
antibodies or increased protection
against mild infection and the
contagious delta variant but scientists
at the world health organization came
out against u.s booster plans saying
more doses should be sent to developing
countries before giving third shots to
americans supporters of distributing
booster shots now point to israel which
already approved pfizer's third dose a
study from that country says the shot
increased protection against severe
illness nearly 20-fold in people 60 and
older but fda reviewers this week warned
against relying on studies from other
countries because the agency hadn't
independently verified the data or their
conclusions and in a medical journal two
top fda vaccine regulators said the
unvaccinated are still the major drivers
of transmission and rejected the booster
for now we will not be silent about 46
of americans are not yet fully
vaccinated and the shifting messages on
a booster aren't likely to help
in an attempt to clear up any confusion
white house press secretary jensachi
said yesterday the white house is
listening only to those that support
booster shots doctors medical
professionals who support booster shots
she says the federal government will be
ready to distribute them whenever the
fda says go tony
all right ed thank you very much for